- It's just impossible, it's impossible,
I keep using social
media, I can't only text.
This is, this is too difficult.
(upbeat music)
- Today we are here to not use products
that women have made for an entire day.
- I think it's gonna be
like, oh yeah, that's fine
it's just a day, but I feel
like I'm going to be wrong
and today's going to be horrible.
- I think there's gonna be a lot of things
that we don't expect on this list,
that we're not gonna be able to use.
- Some things that I knew already
that were invented by women.
We are going to pick from this bowl,
each one's gonna be an
invention and we're gonna guess
if it was a man or a woman who made it.
Improved can opener,
I didn't even know there was
an unimproved can opener.
- I'm gonna say a dude.
- Computer software.
- Woman
Touch tone phone, caller ID, call waiting.
- I'm gonna say a lady.
- I'm gonna agree, windshield
wiper, I'm gonna say dude.
- I'm gonna say a woman,
because I'm pretty sure
they're driving, it's
raining, she's like honey
you can't see, you need like something
to clear the windshield
wiper, he's like, I got this,
okay Cheryl, I got it,
and so she was like,
let me think of something,
so he doesn't kill me.
- Gas heating furnace, I'm
gonna say a guy built this.
- I agree.
- Square bottom paper bag,
I'm gonna say guy on this
- [Woman] All of these
are female inventions.
(laughing)
- Shut the fuck up.
- Oh man!
- Really?
- That's wild, that's so cool.
- Now that we know all these
things were invented by women,
we're gonna try to do
the day without them,
it's gonna be bad.
- It's gonna be bad.
- Yeah.
- Everything that was invented by women
has essentially advanced
the current day and age
of how we live 'cause I feel
like I'm a damn caveman.
It was harder than I thought.
The phone's probably gonna be
the hardest challenge today.
It's during the week so I
don't have to drink beer,
I don't really need anything else.
Just kinda seeing the list I was like,
okay I think I can do
this, it's just a day,
now, by the end of it,
I was pretty frustrated,
the hardest challenge was
not using anything on my cellphone.
So I just got out of the
restroom and of course
I right away started using
social media on my phone.
We're not allowed to use
our cellphones at all
and the fact that I went
straight to the restroom
and went straight to all
my apps and Instagram,
this is gonna be harder than I thought.
- I kind of enjoyed, you know the kind of
disconnecting in a way, it's kind of
just like liberating a little bit.
It's been harder and
harder to do certain things
like technology wise,
we can't use the wifi,
we can't use the GPS, so I don't know how
I'm supposed to do work,
you know send emails out.
- The biggest challenge for me was having
really bored poops, like I would go poop
and I can't go on any apps on my phone,
so I'm just sitting
there staring at a wall.
So it's round two of the
most boring poop ever.
I was kicked out of my desk
because it happened to be cold.
They wanted to put on the
heater, which I can not use,
so I'm officially kicked out and I have to
sit somewhere else, so
now I have to be cold
and wifi-less, really a step back in time.
- Went in to go grocery shopping
and when I was checking out,
the checkout person asked me
if I wanted brown paper
bag or a plastic bag
and I was like, oh shoot, no,
I'm just gonna hold my stuff.
And we're not allowed to use
square bottom paper bags,
so instead I have my
food chilling with me.
I caught myself, she was like
would you like a paper bag?
I was like no, I do not want a paper bag.
- I couldn't go on Netflix,
'cause that was kinda a thing,
I couldn't stream on my computer.
I have nothing to watch
because I can't use wifi
which means I can't use any
entertainment whatsoever,
or internet, or Netflix,
or Hulu, or anything else.
Overall it was way more seemingly
difficult than I thought
and it just made me really
appreciate these women.
- There's a lot of great
everyday inventions that
are made our lives easier
that have been made
by women and you know, sometimes you
just gotta sit back and
appreciate those things.
(upbeat music)